je suis donc la brée apollinaire
policier de son état
ça étonne beaucoup d'hommes mais c'est
ça en fait ma présence ce soit ici est
motivée par une seule raison je suis là
à te parler
je préfère te tutoyer pour créer une
collection parce que le vous çà et là et
les gens dont je suis là pour te parler
at war pour dire que rien n'est
impossible
tu peux tout faire c'est la seule raison
pour laquelle je suis là et je vais le
deuil sera pas mon propre témoignage
simplement je n'ai à lakota à 300 km
d'abidjan au sud-ouest dans un village
après connu boire connu voix est à 17 km
de du chef lieu de département qui a la
cote 1 et donc lorsque le le temps
d'arriver le temps d'aller à l'école
arif et matin à 4h du matin m'a même
river et elle m'annonce que je dois
aller à l'école mais vous savez ce
qu'elle me dit m e el manos que je suis
inscrit dans l'école du bien voisin qui
est à 8 km de notre village alors que
notre ville ait lui-même est doté d'une
école primaire
je lui pose la question de savoir mais
pourquoi mes amis des accusés mais frais
restant maximum françoise et autres et
ils vont à l'école chez nous et moi je
vais de leur côté elle me dit que ce qui
a été décidé donc à 8 m eur tous les
matins elle me réveille à 4 heures et
elle m'accompagne avec les aînés ont
cette école a été fréquenté par les
aînés pas les grains paypal et gras
frais comme les 10 mai avant le jour que
marc rivet elle m'avait dit deux choses
qui auront marqué toute mon existence
est vrai que je vis en concevant comores
mais jusque-là qui m'influence elle me
dit ceci et me dit mon nom parce que je
ne comprenais pas le français
chedid a donc un démon en dix dates des
6 lemaitre et demandé du temps d'appel
après la prune et deuxième chose tu
viens d'une famille de comines et comisa
aux tartines et d'un commissaire les
intellectuels dont il vient d'une
famille d'intellectuels lorsque tu iras
l'école sache que tu viens d'une famille
d'intellectuels et que tu dois défendre
le nom de ta famille j'avoue que depuis
le cp1 jusqu'aujourd'hui je vous parle
ces fameuses intérieur je n'ai jamais
connue mais elle me disait que m a dit
ça et donc moi je vais à l'école j'y
vais au cp1
j'ai fait le cycle primaire g l'entrée
en sixième
on ne m'envoie pas la contacter à 17 km
de mon village mon ma voix dans le chef
de région de divo à 100km pratiquement
de chemin là mon père me dit de moi même
de mes chargés de métrer un tuteur là
bas mon père encore et donc mon frère
mon frère aîné mois on arrive à divo on
va retrouver un tuteur un monsieur
mais ce moment de coulibaly ainsi nous
faut la repenser la diversité varenne et
scie dida est sénoufo me wehrli et donc
je suis chez le monsieur de données
chambre et je vais à l'école et en
cinquième lorsque je suis à 5 m
je veux je vais me faire connaître mais
nous n'oublions pas que je vais du
village et qu'il ya le dépaysement ya
beaucoup de choses mais dix ans est que
mieux les faire connaître à l'église de
la revue catholique je vois le curé de
l'église yvette enfant de choeur les
servants de messe
le club taurin me demande si mon père et
sur l'apparence et le dynamo père au
village on assiste enfin quand il me
prend ici dans le cours de la fin de que
en 4ème au collège rejoindre le club de
d'engrais et le dans le cadre d'un vrai
j'ai fait le théâtre j'ai le bepc en
troisième j'ai relu ses modèles de divo
j'arrive après bien je prends la tête du
club espagnol le club de philosophie
toujours me faire remarquer
et donc finalement je remercie mon papa
le vieux 1,22 coulibaly qui m'a hébergé
jusque là je lui dis que je veux ma
super c'est trop facile que soit elle
que je mange ma démission et je vais
m'assurer je vais pas me prendre une
maison
mon père me dit encore là qu'il n'a pas
assez d'argent et que s'il veut prendre
besoin moi même depuis la maison et la
maison était à 5000 francs
enfin l'heure du lycée donc je prends la
maison mais je trouve une parade tout le
soin à peine d'un coup j'ai fait le coup
à domicile qu'on appelle un cd pour
pouvoir payer la maison mais en même
temps cette petit champlain était devenu
ce qu'on appelle ce qu'on appelle un
lieu de débat lorsqu'il à midi tous les
élèves du lycée viennent là comme
j'étais présent du crack de philosophie
tous les adeptes de ce combiné là pour
déposer intellectuelle le groupe des
bases intellectuelles
c'est comme ça tout la musique j'ai le
bas j'arrive sur la fac à l'université
la première fois j'arrive à bien c'est
pas facile mais encore ali veste et
j'appartiens au club des délégués dans
fille comme le délégué d'un fût est à
prévoir et j'ai mon j'ai ma maîtrise ma
maîtrise de philosophie
je regrette la famille pauvre
mon père veut que je vole toujours de
mes propres ailes ma mère ça va pas que
faut-il faire
aulas le concours de sous officier de
police moi je vais faire du concours un
ami qui m'a dit que ça ne valait pas la
peine on teste jour à la gare nord la
gare centrale à galarraga mais on s'est
séparé après de poisson je suis allé
planter le concours et je suis admis à
ce concours et donc j'intègre la police
en tant que sous-officier en tant que
sous-officier dès que la police est
allée voir
voilà aussi dimanche ça s'anime en date
de 2005 l'année 2005 et donc
sous-officiers de police
est muté à la crs pour la crs à la
préfecture de police d'avoir son nom
lundi si près de paris d'aboisso après
instructeur à l'école de police après
deux corps de police a muté à guiglo à
600 km d'abidjan en 2012
je réalise que ce statut de policier un
sous-officier c'est pas un statut qui
écarte tout de même viable pour
quelqu'un qui est maîtrisards donc jeu
[Musique]
et donc je décide de reprendre mes
études
notre tâche est un guide on est à 600 km
universal a bien baissé au fait du faux
bail que faut-il faire
donc j'ai fait un programme à temps
j'étais secrétaire de monsieur le
commissaire dont nous travaillons tous
les jours
non il arrive des moments où j'ai
demandé des prêts mission des auteurs
des autorisations d'absence
mais lorsque je demande aux deux ans
d'absence je prends le cas à guiglo la
nuit le cas du soir je prends le cas et
j'arrive à abidjan je dors à la gare le
matin je me lave le visage avait
beaucoup sur la face à lui rester dans
le coup finira 16e levée harraga pour
prendre part du soir pour retourner sur
guiglo oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bon appel de 2012 c'est comme ça a
bien fonctionné mais il fallait être en
bons termes avec le commissaire aussi
est donc seul apte à jouer mon humilité
le commissaire c'est vrai j'étais
maintenant était un master et gilson
sécurité à midi c'est moi qui partais
prendrait part à la maison lorsque je
viens je le sais je suis arrêté film de
manger je prends les airs que je lave et
je balaie la maison et je balaie le
secteur du lot ouais et donc j'aime
continue comme ça j'ai fait le masters
il a soutenu le masters après issues des
missions inscrits en thèse à fin de 2014
je continue comme ça je prends le cas
les soit à du gros au radar est vicié à
2 heures du matin je dois la dalle le
lendemain je me lave le visage je
continue sur la fac je fais le coup je
prends le cas du soir et je le trouve
sur guiglo j'arrive agricole à 3 heures
du matin le lendemain c'est au travail
mais en même temps ce qu'il faut aussi
aller je dois aussi précisé c'est depuis
ce temps depuis 2012 jusqu'à 2017
je dormais entre 5h et 7h du mat et
comment est-ce que je m'arrangeais je
quitte le travail et à 18h 19h je suis
avec les enfants du père de famille et
je suis avec les enfants 23 de réformes
appel de 23,2 jusqu'à 5 ans j'étudie
depuis 23h jusqu'à 5 heures du matin je
bosse à 5 ans je dors à cette ma femme
me réveille je me lave et je vais au
travail et donc c'est ainsi que j'ai
fonctionné jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce que
j'arrive à à la soutenance de ma thèse
de doctorat
le lieu de la soutenance que s'est-il
passé lors de la soutenance
je suis arrivé la veille la veille le
car était tombé en panne tout ça et nous
sommes arrivés très tard à guiglo je
soutiens soutenu le 17
le 17 décembre 2017 et donc j'arrive
donc abidjan la nuit fallait avoir conçu
le lendemain matin et du bon la
soutenance est prévue pour le 20 heures
je vais rapidement allé prendre le
costume l'embouteillage ce jour lundi
avait un véhicule qui était un pardessus
avait un accident sur l'autoroute c'est
l'embouteillage a fait que jusqu'à 9 je
n'ai pas pu avoir le coup ce costume
nous sommes partis de bourgogne
on voulait passer par le bateau n'a pas
pu on a pris un taxi
on l'a encore vu passer par mais aussi
que l'on n'a pas pu finalement la
pinasse la plume place on à travers vous
avez la finale ou à laisser a comme un
peu c'est vrai qu'au bout avec la russie
de là on a traversé est on arrivé au
camp suisse on apprenne aux actionnaires
dont caen puis je suis arrivé mais marc
état de près de cinq minutes alors que
le jury pratiquement été là non pas pour
dire que on peut tout fait moi j'étais
déterminé j'ai eu un esprit d'humilité
et vous ai dit que je servais le
commissaire j'ai balayé je l'avais les
assiettes mais j'étais déterminé parce
qu'il savait où j'allais il n'est pas
question de s'énerver avec un encart
avec un tonton rêve le gouvernement avec
les blancs il aurait fait passer le
tranquille
[Applaudissements]
bon là c'est le temps qui m'est tout
dépend de toi
tout dépend de toi tout dépend de toi tu
peux tout faire
y a rien d'impossible la vie n'a pas été
facile pour moi je suis docteur
aujourd'hui et vous est ce qui s'est
passé le ministre de l'intérieur m'a
appelé et m'a nommé chez d'études dans
son cabinet voici là lors de la super
nes c'est mon épouse qui a coûté c'est
le prochain dead applaudi les
professeurs est bon et donc tu peux y
arriver
lorsque moi je le garde lorsque j'aurai
à l'univers lorsque j'ai arrêté de
regarder par la blâmer ouvert et a su
nous tout perdre le désert et gardent
leurs gardes l'univers ouvert le mode
est ouvert le mode est ouvert là où tu
peux arriver tu peux être tout dépend de
toi tout est hantée mais tout tenté mais
tout intérêt aujourd'hui j'ai respiré
beaucoup de fonctionnaires beaucoup de
professeurs dans la pleine mesure du
panel réinscrit la nouvelle je suis là
bas